j'étais beaucoup de choses par amour
donc je vous faire une interview par
aman ans ne bouge pas pendant le signal
[Musique]
je ferai
m
voilà
non
mais savez moi je vais bien vous faire
votre intérieur je viens de tout ce que
vous voulez mais de ben williams et
depuis quatre ans c'est vraiment pas mon
souci quoi parce que tu es l'amour ggg
tous les brasseries mais je peux pas le
croire et pas depuis quatre ans que j'ai
d'autres choses à attendre jusque là
parce que depuis quatre ans on parlait
plus à roland daynac vous avait pas de
relation amoureuse
je parle de 2 kg pas chez lui d'autres
chats à fouetter obama devait pas me
dire que depuis quatre ans tu as vu des
mondes quand même un
vide et monde qui parle père roland
dumas - taggeurs roland garros a redit
[Musique]
depuis quatre ans je fais peur avec tout
ce qui m'arrive parce que imaginez vous
un homme m'approche vous savez ce qu'il
risque depuis quatre ans alors des
pompes 9
et finir avec
judiciaire les annonces du site habbo
piscine on va faire un test on va le
présenter comme un
contrôle fiscal
n'était pas déchiré
décourager des graves
les emmerdements
un
but un peu rang
bon alors
moi je comprends pas il ya des messieurs
pour moi qui rit
ça va vite ah oui ça va très vite est-ce
que par un mot vous soyez prêtes à
quitter la france
sans amour pour vous exiler au paraguay
n'importe où n'importe souffle est-ce
que par amour vous soyez prêtes à faire
évader roland dumas avec un hélicoptère
j'aurais pu le faire par à manger pour
lui j'ai fait c'est presque six mois de
prison
est-ce que par amour vous accepteriez
d'avoir recours à la chirurgie
esthétique
je ferai pour mal pour moi pour
l'instant de moi j'ai envie de me vaut
mieux dans une tête un peu les nichons
elle son bien une journée non ils sont
précis un truc les
hôtels via ses
patins lien
formidable tête
j'avais à notre nouvelle idole ici c'est
une des gogos garde de corti faut dire
des choses un talent ya elle est là mais
l'italien
axa be
bon alors justement ça rejoint le votre
bouquin est ce que par un mot vous
seriez prête à vivre à trois avec sa
maîtresse
oui vous êtes soir me dabo
vous savez je trouve que finalement
pourquoi pas moi de toute façon les
femmes me déçoivent je parle pas d'une
façon sexuelle mais je pense que les
femmes aujourd'hui sens pour moi un
exemple de déjà de courage
lorsque les satisfactions je parle de
vie parce qu'il ya pas que du sexe toute
la journée
d'accord d'accord donc j'aime j'aime la
compagnie des femmes depuis quatre ans
les seuls exemples ouvrage de truc c'est
les femmes ah ben voilà vous voulez que
je vous donne un bel exemple de courage
oui j'ai envie de le faire je peux oui
eh bien j'ai une avocate qui s'appelle
sophie beauté qui a eu le courage de
prendre un dossier qu'elle ait le
courage pendant le procès de risque et
six mois de prison pour sortir le
dossier des frégates qu'elle a posé sur
le comptoir du comme on a dit au
tribunal devant le juge elle risquait
six mois de prison et 7 femmes je sais
ce soit qu'on lui rende hommage thierry
parce que cette femme est en train
d'essayer de sortir de l'enfer le petit
michael blanc et je crois que c'est
logique seulement je crois que ce sera
d'avoir une pensée
si elle est michaël blanc
et voilà
le
ouais mais voilà talia tient données
italien parce que christine de vous
connaître justement
oui merci je pense que tu as tonnerre va
rester l'absolu montagne à jour restez
là vous êtes invitée permanente de
l'émission jusqu'au mois de juillet bien
alors est-ce que alors bouclé sauf
est-ce que
par amour vous auriez accepté de vivre
avec l'amant de votre femme quand on
aime on ne compte pas quoi enfin
tu vois je
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
aller tous les samedis soir dans un club
échangiste
non je crois pas ça la reine du dessous
de table dans un club échangiste
on arrive maintenant une question qui
vient de clotilde courau ou connaissait
clotilde courau qui est en préventive
clotilde courau c'est une comédienne qui
quand elle était plus jeune embrasser
mille fois par amour les chaussettes
sales de son jules
auriez pas ça soyons pas non non
vraiment bon tir et les bancaires sont à
la peine
de faire six mois de présence et des
japonais c'est déjà pas mal des
chaussettes sales en prison doit revoir
c'est vrai alors est-ce que paramore
vous seriez prête à prendre 20 kilos
parce qu'il aime les rues ben oui puis
ça me ferait pas de mal j'en ai perdu 13
en prison donc ça va vous êtes ça serait
bien oui même pas que par amour est-ce
que par amour ou seriez prête à cacher
le corps de la personne qu'il vient de
tuer tout à fait
même pour rien qu'elle ses décors ses
intérêts mais une relation non parce que
ce sont les deux choses les plus
importantes et je crois plus encore à la
métier qu'est l'amour et si un jour un
ami m'appelle dans la nièvre jeune corps
givet jules aide et je lui demande pas
ni pourquoi ni comment je le fais c'est
bien c'est pour moi aller c'est bien de
voir les derniers comme vous dites dans
oui mais oui j'ai beaucoup d'amis comme
ça mais des condiments alors est-ce que
par un mot vous seriez prête à faire du
trafic d'influencé pour couvrir du
trafic d'armes international
sheva
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux